investigators want to know how a lion
escaped from an enclosure before killing
an intern at a wildlife conservatory in
North Carolina 22 year old Alexandra
Black was helping clean out the big cats
quarters yesterday when she was attacked
Janet shamlian is outside the
conservators Center in Burlington about
50 miles northwest of Raleigh Janet good
morning good morning this is a horrific
incident and the animal refuge center is
now closed until further notice
the question that investigators are
trying to answer how did this lion get
out of what handlers say was a secure
and locked area
this is Mathai the lion the conservators
Center in North Carolina says somehow
escaped a locked area before attacking
Alexandra black an intern who'd been
there only ten days
it happened alongside a trained animal
keeper during a routine cleaning of the
lion's cage there were visitors on site
but we used our established safety
protocol to ensure a safe and immediate
exit from the Animal Park handlers tried
to tranquilize the male lion several
times but eventually were forced to
shoot Maathai to remove the young
woman's body she was 22 Alex's friends
called her recently graduated from
Indiana University Bloomington and hopes
someday to be a zoo keeper her
brokenhearted family calling this her
fourth internship working with animals
saying she was a beautiful young woman
who had just started her career she died
pursuing her passion I can't imagine the
loss they're enduring I can't imagine
what it must feel like to be them we
only knew this person is a short time
but obviously it was already devastating
for us the 10 acre refuge is home to
more than 80 animals including more than
a dozen African lions many rescued from
poor conditions workers typically
interact with the big cats daily through
feedings and maintaining their habitats
we're all still processing this is not a
situation we've ever had before any sort
of incident like this is devastating to
everyone and we need to understand it
the conservative Center said it is
cooperating with the investigation but
that it has never had anything
like this happened here meanwhile Alex
Black's family is asking for donations
in her honor to another animal refuge
wolf park in battleground Indiana
Michelle tragic Janet thank you